[موسيقى]
دمج كلتا السيارتين
في الطائرة في الواقع الجديد هو
الحل الثوري الذي سيغير
نقل الأشخاص على النطاق العالمي
لمجرد الانتقال من A إلى B من الباب
إلى الباب ، الأمر يتطلب الكثير من  الوقت الذي
سيحل فيه الكثير من المشاكل الحالية
، تأسست الشركة في عام 2010
قبل سبع سنوات عندما
وجدت السيارات الطائرة الكثير من الخيال العلمي ، قمنا
بالفعل ببناء نموذجين أوليين سابقين
كانا في الواقع يتدفقان ويقودان في
الشارع وفي الهواء السيارة خلفها
أنا تمثل أول
مركبة تجارية نبدأ في تلقي الطلبات المسبقة
للمركبة الأولى في أول عمليات التسليم
في عام 2020
[موسيقى]
نحن نعتمد السيارة بموجب
تعليم airsoft وستكون السيارة التالية
بالطبع FAA ثم وكيلها
شهادة
[موسيقى]